The Joe Rogan experience. How long have you been teaching this for this class?
Yeah, such wildness.
That's another one. That's a post-tenure. Uh, but it's, um,
probably been about seven or eight years. Yeah.
So how much the, this is a really important question. Like as a professor,
what is it like pre tenure and post tenure?
Because it seems to be a night and day difference in terms of freedom and right.
I, I overplay that event.
But everyone does not you everyone, I guess.
Yeah. It's a strange, a whole, um, uh, organization,
you know, and, and logic, the higher education I'm opposed to tenure.
I think it's. Yeah. Um, absolutely.
Texts, intellectual freedom. No, anyway.
I mean, I'm thinking there was a time in which we might make that argument, but,
um, you know, uh, I don't know who else has tenure, um,
when other professions it's a good question. It's not insane.
It's like not the real world. And, um.
Do you think it's in some ways, um,
not good because then the,
almost like you, if the, the intellectual version of being born wealthy,
like you, uh you're you're you have no worries. And so you,
you almost become spoiled.
Yeah. No, well, yes, absolutely. I mean, you know, there, there,
there are arguments that after, um,
some faculty get tenure or they shut down or they really aren't doing as much
research anymore and there isn't that drive. Right. I mean,
it's a whole tiered system, so you move,
you get tenure when you move from assistant to associate professor and then,
you know, what you want to get to is full professor. Right. Right. And again,
that's the sort of that, just a different, um, um, place in the hierarchy. Yeah.
And what is that again? It's all the papers. You write books, you publish.
I mean, yeah, my humanities, it's getting a couple books out there.
Um, but, but yeah, I mean, I,
I can't deny that I felt much freer
after I got, uh, after I, uh, got tenure to, uh,
explore, um, topics that I would be more hesitant to explore.
Which topics in particular drugs, drugs.
For sure. Drugs. Um, as, again, as a, as a, as a research area, full,
full force, you know, kind of go into it again, because there's a,
um, legitimate purpose to, um, a scholarly study of,
of the connections between religion and drugs. It's, uh,
luckily I'm not the only one who was pursuing this, but, um, but it's,
it's, uh, I, I believe, um,
there are a lot of interesting connections that haven't been made,
especially in, in contemporary American society. The other,
the other drug that I'm particularly interested in and seems to, um,
get a lot of response is that I also include pharmaceuticals and
prescription psychoactive drugs as a part of the drugs and
religion connection. And, um,
so looking at the pharmaceutical industry and pills is, um,
sort of religious objects and structures and cultures really,
uh, how so? Well, um.
Like anti-anxiety medication.
Or, yeah, I mean, that is just a kind of, you know, it's ritualized.
So you put it, you know, you, you've got to make sure, you know,
you take it and take it when you're supposed to take it.
You put faith in this little magic pill that is effective and can,
um, bring you to a better place. Um,
it has importance in terms of community and who you are
connected with and how the drug allows you to,
to have certain kinds of community. Um,
so a lot of this is obviously kind of a message.
Do you see the messages in pharmaceutical commercials,
which are for me dripping with kind of religious sentiments and sensibilities,
you can be saved, you know, where you saved you're well,
you're saved with a pill.
So this is a subject in particular that like pre-tenure would be,
you'd have to be walking on eggshells.
Um, again, drugs more generally. I would, I would, I w yeah,
I would not be necessarily going there, but, you know, I mean, I'm not sure.
Do other professors share your perspective on tenure that that's kind of
nonsense, um, or? I should say.
I would say, um, yeah, there are some, but, um, I honestly enjoy it though.
I think most people would like to keep it and think it serves some function in
terms of, as you're saying, sort of, um, sort of legit legitimacy of,
of academic.
Some people are internally motivated.
Some people are motivated just by, um, whatever drives them,
but whatever intellectual curiosity, they're their goals, whatever it is,
it has nothing to do with, um,
financial stability or job stability, but not, not,
not most. Yeah. Most people,
if you give them 100% job security, they're going to get fat.
Yeah. I'm afraid. I, uh,
I would agree. Absolutely. It's weird. And, and you're right.
Some people are just, um, you know, just motivated. They want to succeed and,
and pursue, um, their interests sort of,
no matter what. Um, and, and there are certainly a number of,
of scholars who are like, that sure would make their way to the top.
Path is what interests them. Right. The, the, the, the destination.
Right, exactly. I think that's exactly right. And, um, you know,
but as I sort of joked earlier, I joke that I, you know,
this is called a work and I don't feel I really work. Right. I have a great,
great job. I just, I love I do well, you nailed.
It. Right. You figured out what actually interests you.
And for some people that what you do would be work, but not for you.
Well, right. Exactly. I mean, again,
I'm very fortunate that especially being at Emory, um,
so it's, it's a different kind of, um, professional life that I, again,
it's just, I've been really fortunate and, uh, it wasn't planned, you know,
I was a up. And, uh, as I write about in this new book, you know,
don't think about death, which is a memoir on mortality. Um,
I was directionless and just around at high school and getting high and
taking all kinds of drugs. How dare you. Yeah.
Can you believe that in the San Fernando Valley.
That's weird. You were doing that in the San Fernando Valley. No one does that.
No, you must have been a rebel. Yeah. Right.
Conformity, but, Oh my God, what part of the Valley did you live in? Van Nuys.
Oh.
Okay. Our old studio was in Woodland Hills.
Right. And, and, and on one of your guys grew up in the Valley,
so I got shorter.
Yeah. Was fun. I used to work out in van Nuys. It's where the Benny,
the jets jet center was. Oh, right, right. No, that was funny. Well, famous.
Kickbox one of the first places I came to when I came to California,
couldn't wait to go to the Jetstar because you had heard about it. Oh my God.
It was legendary. Benny Markita is like a legendary kickboxer, uh,
in the early days of kickboxing. And he came out of Los Angeles.
Yeah. It's so funny.
How many people come out of San Fernando Valley are connected? I mean,
that's like, it's not that funny. Well, a lot of people out there. Yeah. Well,
but in any case, I was, uh, I was on a different path and luckily came around.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st to December 1st,
they're going to be available everywhere. But after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking you just go download Spotify much. Buh-bye.
Okay.